عندما ذهبت إلى
شقة والدك هنا وفي الولايات المتحدة ،
تكتشف شيئًا
جعلك تدرك مدى أهمية
أحفاده بالنسبة له ، ماذا كان
يذهب إلى الشقة التي ربما كانت
أكثر اللحظات العاطفية التي مررت بها في هذا
أفضل  هناك هذه الصورة خاصة أنها
كانت بجوار الخلاطات على سريره وبعض
أحفاده وهذا هو آخر
شيء نظر إليه قبل أن يذهب إلى الفراش
إنه صدمني وكأنه ليس
قصيرًا ولكنه أظهر لنا أنني
لست شيئًا لكن  لقد ركز
على جانبه اللطيف من محبة
أسرته لأحفاده وكان آخر شيء
كان هنا في الليل هو
أحفاده وقد وضع ذلك
حتى يرى نعم إنه مجرد شيء ضخم
وقد لامسني شخصيًا أنا أطفال
وكل شيء  من العائلة عندما تعرف
ذلك ، انظر ما الذي تفتخر به لأنه كان
يقول الحقيقة دائمًا مثل الإنسان الأساسي
مجرد شخص جيد بهذه البساطة
وكان شجاعًا جدًا أنه كان دائمًا
خارج  بالنسبة لي كان مثل نجم موسيقى الروك أند رول
وجاريد كصحفي مثل
لأنك نظام ودائمًا ما
يدفع بأنه كان دائمًا نعم إنه شجاع ،
كان هناك أشخاص
يحاولون نوعًا ما خلق انطباع مختلف
عنه  مزاعم إرث مختلفة
بأنه كان نوعًا ما
يدعم جماعة الإخوان المسلمين ، لا
أعتقد ذلك حتى تتمكن من إلقاء الضوء على هذا
الأمر السهل تمامًا مثل المرة الأخيرة التي قابلته فيها
في تركيا ، أوسمت مثل ، لقد فعلت
هذا على Twitter مثلهم '  أقول لك
الإخوان المسلمين ، أين لحيتك
مرهقة وهو يضحك وحاول أن
يخبرنا بالتفاصيل أنا لست مسلمًا ، بل لا
بسبب هذا ، هذا غير مرجح ،
لقد سمعت ذلك ، نعم ، إنه مجرد تسميات أو
مجرد أشخاص لا يؤدون واجباتهم المدرسية.
قراءة مقالته بشكل صحيح في الانخفاضات ، لذا
من الأسهل عليهم فقط
لصق ملصق عليه كأنك شيئًا
ما أنت ،
يمكنك إخبارنا عن ذلك الاجتماع مع
ولي العهد و  الملك نعم في ذلك
لقاء الملك في
ولي عهدهم عندما ذهبت إلى هناك مع عمي
سال ، أكد الملك أن كل شخص
معني سيتم تقديمه إلى العدالة
ولدي إيمان بأن هذا سيحدث ،
فأنت تضع إيمانك بالملك
نعم في قلبك.  ماذا
تعتقد أنه حدث شيئًا سيئًا
قد يكون شيئًا ما ، لكنني آمل حقًا
أن يكون كل ما حدث
هو أنه لم يكن مؤلمًا بالنسبة له أو
شيء من هذا القبيل أو كان سريعًا
أنه كان لديه موت سلمي كما كنت
أتمنى  لست متأكدًا ، أعني مجرد
انتظار ظهور الحقائق ، إنه
بالنسبة لي مجرد موت ، أعلم أنه
مات ، كل ما أنتظره هو
أن ينتهي التحقيق حتى تظهر الحقائق
كيف تعتقد
أن والدك سيفعل  تريد أن نتذكرها
كرجل معتدل دخل في الحفلة
مع كل شخص صادق حقيقي رجل
أحب بلده الذي آمن
به كثيرًا ،
ولم يكن جيما المحتمل أبدًا معارضًا
عن النظام الملكي ، فقد كان يؤمن بأن هذا هو الشيء
الحفاظ على تماسك الدولة
وكان يؤمن بالتحول
الذي يمر به
وهذه هي الطريقة التي يجب أن
نتذكرها